a quiet place as triumphantly tiptoed
into theaters enjoying critical acclaim
as well as success at the box office
director John Krasinski delivers a
thriller with a unique concept and a
cleverly limited set of cinematic tools
unlike most modern mainstream movies
it's a film that relies less on spoken
dialogue than on ambient sounds of
visuals and mystery a quiet place
introduces the Abbott family who tried
to survive on their secluded farm after
a worldwide invasion of creatures our
hunt by sound getting by with a variety
of creative sound dampening solutions
and communicating with sign language
they face the challenges of adolescence
guilt and even a pregnancy their story
builds to a climax that wraps up the
action while leaving a few questions
still unanswered if you want to know
more about just what went down in the
final minutes keep quiet and check out
our spoiler filled rundown this is the
ending of a quiet place explained
Rockets red glare in a quiet places
opening scene youngest child beau
proposes that a rocket ship could help
the family escape its fascination with
space travel proves to be as downfall as
a toy shuttle in his hands makes enough
electric noise to attract one of the
creatures his family watches helplessly
as a boy is snatched away just before
the main title Beau's death informs a
character arcs for the rest of the story
as a film jumps ahead a year and finds
everyone struggling with grief and guilt
while attempting to maintain some sense
of normalcy under the oppressive silence
his memory plays a key role in the
finale as the monsters move in a
Neverland Albert when she goes into
labor
her husband lien their son Marcus to
draw them away by putting into action a
one-word plan rockets while the farm
glows red with the warning lights a
signal an attack a volley of fireworks
distracts the beast and allows Lea to
take back the house and rejoin his wife
and newborn son sacrificial scream one
of the quiet places central plot threads
focuses on Lee and Evelyn's daughter
Ragan and her strained relationship with
her father as the one who gave Bo the
toy that led to his death Ragan thinks
that Lee blames her Lee's overprotective
tendencies towards his deaf daughter
don't exactly help her feel that he
believes in her either in one of the
film's key scenes
Marcus reminds his father that he needs
to tell Reagan how much he loves her it
is a huge emotional payoff then when the
rescues Marcus and Reagan from a
creature and tells him that he has
always loved them while the kids take
shelter inside a pickup truck of the B
chlorine to get inside he lets out one
final anguish scream giving his life to
save them as they throw the truck into
neutral and it rolls back to the house
it's a cathartic moment not only for the
three characters but for the audience as
well to break the silence with a tragic
but triumphant emotional release all
ears
the greatest mystery of a choir plays
remains the creatures themselves aside
from some vague news headlines there is
barely any exposition given about where
they come from what just how the
invasion went down for most of the
film's runtime the monsters are glimpsed
only briefly appearing as fleeting
players or fake shapes the climax
however finally reveals them in all
their gruesome glory as one of them
storks evelyn and her newborn baby into
the basement of the farmhouse they have
eyeless heads that splits open in all
directions to expose sensitive hearing
membranes in addition to delivering a
horrific visual this design explains a
physiology that allows the beasts are so
accurately strike it even the subtlest
sounds ferocious feedback a unique
aspect of a quiet places its use of
American sign language to convey the
vast majority of the dialogue Kaczynski
chose to hire a deaf actress to portray
the hearing-impaired Regan for the sake
of authenticity and he well to have her
to develop signing habits and styles
that informed each family member's
attitude and character arc the monsters
weakness is a last revealed to be
feedback as the noise emitted from
Reagan's cochlear implant when they are
near confuses their heightened sense and
racks them with pain during the final
confrontation Regan discovers a pile of
discarded custom boosted implants that
Lee had been working on showing how much
he cared for her while also providing
her with the ability to fight back for
the first time
locked and loaded Regan uses Lee's radio
transmitter to amplify the feedback
causing the intruder to recoil
disoriented and expose its inner
membranes eviden takes the opportunity
of having a clear shot at this weak spot
for the first time and blows nothing
away with a shotgun naturally this is
the kind of loud sound the abbot's have
been avoiding as Lee's security monitors
show the other two creatures known to
inhabit the area racing toward the
farmhouse but Evelyn's ready this time
and gives her daughter a reassuring
smile as she [ __ ] a shotgun in the
movie cuts to credits sending the
audience out of the theater without
releasing their adrenaline high the next
generation
Evelyn's pregnancy and labor are a
driving source of tension for most of a
quiet place and it's not just to harvest
the audience's anxieties a major theme
of the film is to struggle to survive
and adapt to some kind of normalcy in
the midst of horrific societal changes
that's why the invasion occurs before
the story begins and their rebellion
against the monsters are saved for after
it's ending Evelyn and leaves newborn
baby serves as a symbol for the belief
that life can go on children will be
born who never knew life before the
quiet
Reagan Marcos and the baby at their
mother's side in the film's final
moments represent what this story is all
about the future thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love today